un soir et vous vient l'envié de
recevoir chez vous à dîner isabelle
adjani céline dion paris s'il tonne
cécilia sarkozy ou ségolène royal
elles ne sont pas liés qu'à cela ne
tienne invités florence foresti
ce sera bien mieux et beaucoup plus
drôle en plus elle viendra avec bernie
le bouledogue dont elle ne se sépare
jamais sauf sous la douche que même
bernie ne sera pas dans l'abribus la
comédie de et avec philippe elno qu'elle
joue au théâtre de la gaîté montparnasse
à partir du 17 janvier ni dans si
c'était lui le film d'anne marie etienne
avec carole bouquet et marc lavoine dans
lequel la maîtresse de bernie est en
quête d'un amoureux bernie n'est pas au
courant
[Musique]
pas du tout trop beau mon chien trop
beau mascotte idole icône de la beauté
mon chien non j'adore il bloque c'est
possible et des chiens tu te lèves tu
rigole beaucoup plus drôle que cas qu'un
joli labrador caramel
tu
j'ai pas beaucoup bagarre avec ma mère
même quand j'étais chiante à
l'adolescence j'étais très insupportable
elle est toujours parti du principe
qu'il valait mieux me faire confiance et
qui fait que je n'avais pas très envie
de la trahir ni lui mentir du coup on a
des relations très respectueuse on n'est
pas non plus les familles
d'intellectuels je pense qu'elle avait
juste une peut-être envie de me m'ouvrir
des trucs quoi d'ailleurs elle
m'emmenait aussi au café théâtre j'étais
trop jeune j'ai pleuré
si la srp descente qu'elle m'ait fait
découvrir des choses qui n'étaient pas
de mon âge après le mouvement dé voir
aussi les pièces de théâtre tout à fait
tragique ou alors elle nous réveillait
le soir ce que nous faisons à 20 heures
après ulysse 31 sur l'a3 au lit elle
nous réveiller que quand il y avait un
film digne d'intérêt pour elle qu'elle
m'a réveillé réveiller pour molière
darhmouch kim quatre heures
[Musique]
c'est pas que c'est le rire intelligent
c'est tout moi c'est un rire qui me
touche parce que les angoisses de mort
ça me touche le personnage de woody
allen en lui-même me fait rire parce
qu'on voit c'est vrai qu'un fils sans
lui s'il n'est pas dedans ça m'emmerde
moi j'aime quand ça traite de
deux familles les parents de les roses
de sexuel l'amitié beaucoup c'est des
thèmes que j'aime en fait c'est m et
puis c'est vrai que quand j'étais un peu
plus jeune je voulais que ma vie
ressemble un film de louisiane mais qui
est du jazz dans la rue qui est des
vitrines de noël dont new york
comprennent des taxis comme ça en levant
la main je voulais que ma vie soit comme
ça et puis qu'on passe des heures à 1,10
à disserter dans un café où on écoutait
du jazz et puis moi ces phrases sur la
morge df quoi je me les approprier je
veux bien mourir mais je veux pas être
là le jour où ça arrivera à quoi alors
ça j'adore son angoisse de mort parce
que j'ai la même nuit à 5 ans j'avais
peur de mourir je jouais pas vieillir et
puis j'ai dit je vais mourir je vais
jamais me réveiller au secours mais
c'est pas grave hein soyez pas plomber
en toi vous allez tous mourir
j'ai juste plus peur que les autres
je crois que c'est naïf de croire que
personne ne se pose la question je crois
que tout le monde se la pose tout le
monde avec lui en voyage à différents
degrés quoi mais tout le monde achète
question à se poser un jour chacun il
répond comme ils peuvent sa part la
religion ne va pas marcher pas les gens
qui qui se perdent dans le travail pour
pas y avoir à y penser
donc voila moi le jeu c'est vraiment le
seul moyen que j'ai trouvé pour oublier
ce à quoi ne serait ce que 2 minutes par
jour toujours ça de pris
l'alcool aussi ça fonctionne ah si
j'étais lui je ne serais pas un peu tard
tiens voilà du boudin
voilà du boudin ou lit j'ai dû dire un
jour à cette photographe marianne
rosenstiehl café est des plus belles
séances photos que j'ai jamais eu de
beaucoup de choses dans ce métier on est
toujours un trait mise en valeur je lui
avais dit qu'elle avait su rendre malade
de rebelles mais oui le mot est fort
laideur certainement j'en ai un peu
souffert oui à l'adolescence parce que
j'étais plus le bon copain que la très
jolie fille du lycée
ceci dit j'ai revu ya pas longtemps la
jolie fille du système boudin maintenant
donc ce qui est bon et calais d'heure
c'est qu'on ne peut que s'améliorer
et alors déjà les jolies ça et oui mais
donc ça c'est chouette parce que j'ai
remarqué que les filles qui étaient très
belles sont souvent très triste parce
que vieillissant sont très tristes voilà
en tout cas chez les humoristes vous
remarqué très souvent que les humoristes
ont été des grands complexes et où le
sont toujours
donc lui l'humour et le rire ça vient
souvent pallier le déficit de estime de
soi
j'aime bien les gueules cassées quoi
j'aime pas les gens trop lisse quoi je
suis plutôt sean penn que brad pitt
je ne venais pas affreux 1 loin de là
mais il a vécu quoi j'aime mieux les
gueux un peu abîmée mais mon mari est
très beau ceci dit c'est souvent pour ça
qu on dit que fac les femmes belles sont
pas drôles par exemple c'est un cliché
mais c'est un peu vrai mais c'est pas
grave
parfois tout avoir non plus hein ça
c'est une période sa région
personne n'a cette coupe en 2005 on
n'est pas loin ben par mafalda qui a une
dérogation elle qui a obligé à me le
dire n'ont pas non dans la vie change
pas comme ça dans la vie c'est une
grande blonde chatoyantes symbolique
c'est souvent que ils sont tellement
belles qu'elles n'ont pas eu besoin de
raconter des blagues pour être serré le
regard comme justice merde ou crépus
qu'elle soit drôle en plus parce que ça
n'existe pas les prothèses de cornes
moche
on peut pas se briser du corps doit vous
voilà donc c'est l'original et ça reste
assez super oui surtout quand je fais ça
j'adore faire ça pour moi la grâce est
ailleurs c'est diane keaton dans dans
annie hall elle habille en quarts sont
des pieds à la tête
merveilleuse de féminité
[Musique]
le mot de la fin c'est que la nuit tombe
que ma fille m'attends donc je vais
aller remplir mon plus beau rôle celui
de maire
non je vais aller donner le biberon quoi
il ramasse et kaka ma vie
[Musique]